Here's the Sent Memes view, it's
the first screen presented upon launch.
The Sent Memes view keeps track
of all recently sent memes.
Here you can see a few that I
sent to my teammates earlier.
You can see the memes in a table view or
a grid.
Notice how I can switch back and
forth using these tabs.
When I press the grid icon,
the collection view appears.
When I press the table icon
the table view appears.
The grid is created using a UI
collection view controller.
It's similar to the UI
table view controller but
has a more flexible layout mechanism.
Both of these views access
the same meme model objects, and
they're embedded in
a tab bar controller.
>From the Sent Memes page, the user
can go back and create new memes.
When I press the button with the plus
icon in the right corner the meme
editor slides up from the bottom.
Now I can make a new meme.
Here I'll make one about my
favorite cow on the beach.
And of course when we're done with
our new meme we'll want to share it.
Here, let's send this one to Sebastian.
When the meme has been sent,
the meme editor slides back down and
the Sent Memes view is revealed again.
And this time the collection
includes the new cow meme.
And that's meme me 2.0.